I just threw a truck and a dragon I love
my life
like a lightning bolt from the sky this
week's selections for what to watch are
sure to leave a mark on your weekend
watch list ouch along with the return of
Shazam this week we're lassoing in a
couple of new seasons for two shows that
we already know you love and we're lucky
to bring you some debut seasons for two
shows that we think you're gonna love
you can trust us it's kind of what we do
from soccer to climate change and lots
in between Rotten Tomatoes is delivering
the goods on this week's what to watch
children's talk the power of all the
gods
small Billy
striking down in theaters is Shazam Fury
of the Gods the follow-up to 2019
certified fresh Shazam among the reasons
to watch is that this one features the
return of Zachary Levi as a Shazam along
with director David F Sandberg from the
first one we'll also see the whole
Shazam Ali as Levi calls it in both
their civilian and superhero forms that
we were introduced to at the end of the
first movie but of course it's not all
good guys as they'll be facing quite the
trio villains this time around we're
talking Helen Mirren as his Spira Lucy
Liu as Calypso and Rachel zegler as
Anthea collectively known as the
daughters of Atlas
um yeah that's gonna be hard not to have
a love interest right well you may not
want to ask the cast Billy Shazam
does not have a love no he does not
clear however
somebody else might so Freddy
[Music]
[Applause]
I love you guys so very much I'm free
one two three
and taking the field for its third
season is the hit dramedy series Ted
lasso and to no one's surprise season 3
is certified fresh at 94 now you can
scream goal and freak everyone around
you out or read the critics consensus
Ted lasso's third and possibly final
season takes time to find its footing
but patient viewers who believe will
find that they appreciate coach as much
as ever the mile long list of reasons to
watch this Apple TV Plus show starts
with its 11 total Emmy wins including
two for best comedy series yep it's that
good and no word yet on if this will be
the final season but show creators have
said that the story that they set out to
tell had a three season Arc so this very
well could be the end of something
special and if it's not win-win for all
of us are you willing to sacrifice
which is most precious to you
emerging from the darkness with its
second season is the Netflix shows
Shadow and Bone coming off a certified
fresh fur season this fantasy series
he's back for eight more episodes with
all the main casts returning that
includes Stars Jessie May Lee whose
Alina character has a magical power that
could unite her world AKA she can summon
the sun yeah that would be that'd be
pretty sweet Shadow and bone is based on
two best-selling book series and a World
created by author Lee bardugo and while
season one followed the first book of
the same name season 2 will mirror the
book called Siege and storm with Alina
crossing a big sea to try and start a
new life you bookworms know what I'm
talking about I've been holding on to a
lot of anger towards you
[Music]
you see come on you want a piece of this
arriving with this Premier season is the
AMC show lucky Hank based on the 1997
novel Straight Man by Richard Russo the
main reason to watch is that in
returning to the network that housed his
previous hits Better Call Saul and
Breaking Bad Bob odenkirch stars in this
one as an English department chairman at
an underfunded College who's trying to
balance the madness in both his personal
and professional lives aren't we all
another reason to watch is that onenkirk
also serves as an executive producer for
Lucky Hank along with others including
Peter Farrelly yep of the Fairly
Brothers an even cooler Peter directed
The Pilot for the series that's a mic
drop we bad people
stop being angry angry about
pictures now and because you couldn't
get out of here without someone bringing
up climate change premiering on Apple TV
plus is extrapolations this Anthology
drama series depicts the effects of
climate change on the planet through
interconnected stories and if that
hasn't piqued your interest already
acting out those stories is an
absolutely Stellar cast headlined by
Meryl Streep and includes names like kit
Harrington Toby Maguire Diane Lane
Heather Graham and oh so many more
extrapolations was created by Scott Z
Burns best known for writing movies like
The Bourne Ultimatum and also producing
the oscar-winning doc and Inconvenient
Truth well that's it for this week
plenty of Glorious options for what to
watch whether you're getting out of the
house or chilling on the couch with your
sweats we don't give a Shazam we just
want you to be happy remember to check
out rottentomanos.com for the latest
updates on scores and reviews for
everything mentioned as well as the
movie and TV World At Large and until
next week Shazam stay fresh
foreign